he's one of our favorite guests he is
the Walter Payton Man of the Year
nominee for the team from 2017 where he
had also one of the best years on the
field for the New Orleans Saints who are
heavily thought about as a Super Bowl
contender in 2018 he is defensive end
Kamerion Jordan how are you doing
Cameron
oh I'm blessed and highly favored today
you know we're officially part of week
one I couldn't be more excited for this
upcoming Sunday okay what I mean when
you say excitement walk me through how
you feel two days before taking on the
box at home to kick it all off um like a
kid entering his senior year of high
school okay first day first day feels
you know you come in like hey I got to
make this year the greatest year of my
life
I don't know that next year holds I know
I have to take advantage of every moment
now everything else has changed yeah
after this I'm sure you know so you walk
into this week and you start breaking
down film you're breaking off breaking
down film it's like you look up and it's
9 o'clock at night and you know your
head to you like oh right right right I
definitely got to go to sleep for this
next day you get up the next day you
know today and it's just like that same
day I mean everybody's just super overly
excited to be here everybody's overly
excited to get back on this field and
put in more work and honestly I love the
team hunger right now I'm glad that you
added the extra details to that because
when I walked into my first year of
senior year of high school I was like I
can't stand this place I got this I know
everything I can't wait to get out of
here that was my son you know know you
know you just have more confidence than
I did apparently you know I had a lot to
live up to my senior year house I got
like I'm sort of committed to Cal like
they're gonna be watching my games I've
got it I've got to make this one great
we have different experiences in that
regard
so are you guys hearing in the building
how much people like you to make it to
Atlanta this year and win at all you
guys hearing that um per usual you
trying to an out you know
all forms of media a positive and or
negative and just try and focus on being
the best you can be for this for the
upcoming practice and try you know an
after prayer
which I become as best as you can be
from that practice and just keep on
building days we're trying to lay this
great foundation which we've done over
you know OTAs and summer training to
lead into this week one and week one is
almost here but there's no but you you
you you are tuning that you said
normally you do so are you normally
normally you know we when you say
everything is normal you know we're
gonna keep it as program okay how long
did it take you to get over how your
season ended last year Cameron Jordan uh
I don't know honestly sort of it I'd
like to say sort of fast
uh when I saw you got last you know I
was talking about how I use it as
motivation to to try and better
ourselves push yourselves further than
we have been before but at the same time
you realize you're in a different 53-man
roster you're on a different team and
we've got the same mind set up trying to
win the Super Bowl so if anything that's
gonna just gonna push us beyond what we
did last year well I can you walk me
through I guess in the weeks and months
intervening have you guys talked about
it as a group have any by has anybody
gone up to any of the players involved
in that final play I mean how has it
been put to bed in a way um yeah I mean
after the game you can do nothing but
support your teammates after you know a
week after the game when things cooled
off you can do nothing but you know she
got the text to reason we support your
teammates you could get back to OTAs and
it's nothing but positive reinforcement
of hey this would happen this was you
this is what we needed to happen this is
how we're gonna go about becoming better
as unit and make it more of a unit
rather than trying to force this into
this individual situation we talk about
how we can grow as a unit from you know
the guys that were you know our first
year standouts to making the second year
leap which I think they will from our
second year guys who's gonna make this
third you know this elite to this third
year and from the third year guys we're
gonna jump to this fourth year then you
know you got bringing back a Oh Alex
Okafor and you you know you bring in the
addition stuff Marcus Davenport and I'm
trying to push myself to be better than
I was last year I feel I feel that we
have done everything in our power to
propel ourselves from
that previous season's ending to where
we are now let's talk about that kid for
a second with you Cameron Jordan cuz uh
you know draft night I'm sitting on the
set Saints move up and draft first-round
Lamar Jackson's on the board and we're
all sitting there going okay is this you
know a the the maneuver for New Orleans
to given up a1 to next year's draft to
move up to get drew Brees his successor
and Lamar Jackson and all of a sudden
its Marcus Davenport from a small school
did you even know about this kid when
the Saints went ahead and moved up to
get him to play on the opposite side of
you
um what's funny is you know the previous
year's roster we had a guy from UTSA on
the squad on the practice squad and
Ishod Mabry and he was hyping his guy up
so he ended up here that's yeah I
definitely knew about it my advice and
film on them and he seems overly
talented in some areas in there he has a
large ceiling I mean he has a high
ceiling and a large petition to grow so
what have you been doing to try and
bring on his damn nerves honestly so I'm
on his heels I'm pushing I'm pushing him
to test himself to test his limits to
just try to improve all his pass rush
but focus more on you know get to get to
third down you got to face first and
second you know if he soaks everything
up like a sponge some codes for myself
from Alex Okafor he's trying to take it
all in for he's talking to you know
Sheldon rankings is when the smarter
interior deal I mean you're gonna have
in this league and he's really pushing
his mental capacity at all times so when
I say I'm probably annoying as hell I'm
like hey I like the rest right there but
I feel like you can smooth out some of
this little block so you can get on a
different path you can play on the next
level if you any sort of just give me
any hints and clues that way and I'm
probably like said I'm probably on if
I'm not in and I could see his reps I'm
probably in is he or every every rep I
love it Cameron Jordan here on the Rich
Eisen show is Alvin Kamara ready to
carry the whole load the bell cow I mean
it's him and Gillis Lee right now well
well obviously Mark Ingram is is out for
the first month what do you got for me
on that front
um Alvin is is a pro I mean he came in a
pro it wasn't like he had to adapt
anything he came in and you know I would
even say learn from he learned with how
do how to be a compliment to you know
that tandem of marking him in Alvin
Kamara so let me talk about a cake I let
a cake go to work I mean the kids kids
balance is amazing and we talked about
having a backup who are backup or having
Mike Isley me be sort of compatible with
him we're gonna take missed ride here
you're gonna see what you can do this
this week does the team view breeze
through the prism of his window closing
just the father time is calling in a way
I have no idea that's something that's
beyond my paygrade I know when I see a
practice and I know what I see a
training camp and I know what I've seen
I've seen in games for the past seven
years of my career prior to this one I
know he's lit it up every every moment
the way when you talk about his demeanor
his mentality he takes the field with
great presence and he he always leaves
it in excellence so drew is on his own
time I don't think the team and or the
players have any expectation that Drew
is nothing but great okay so while we're
on the subject of other people's
business let me hit this a couple of
these subjects with you Cameron Jordan
what'd you think of the colemak and
aaron donald contracts I'm always happy
to see fellow D lineman get paid I'm
always happy to see players make their
money from I mean everybody who got
extension you talk about the nail hunter
you talk about Darrell Casey you know
the to make a mega extensions that's
only gonna bode well for guys like Joey
Bosa in the coming years when you when
you watch it I'm you know you talk about
Dino and Carlos I'm all about players
making the money especially when players
have earned it the way that they have
loved it sort so what I love sort of
like seeing a house down the street from
you sold for a lot of money it's in your
neighborhood I'm a big I love it whether
the house is bigger bigger the same or
smaller I love it well in that regard
Cameron what did you make of the
comments out of Pittsburgh were
offensive linemen protecting levy on
bail normally are talking about him not
being there and think it's not right
that he's not there over money
it's a rare instance of players talking
about other players money in their
presence not being there to get more
money crazy to me yeah that's crazy to
me I stick to I don't speak on their
situation clearly they have a lot of
emotions invested to the team and that's
that's how I have to leave that one
because I feel that you know again I
love when players make the money I love
when loyalty runs both ways between team
and player and to speak on on that
situation maybe I'm outside looking in
but at some point you know look again
loyalty has to run both ways and for
players to talk about players you have
to support your teammates so I can't
speak on it I mean there was a situation
in Pittsburgh where you know team made a
decision and a player decided not to go
with that so said decision hi I can't
speak uh minute I know it's another
person's house in that regard you know
but it just it's so it's so rare to see
I'm wondering is that being has that
been discussed at all in your locker
room that those committed oh we're
focused on we're focused on the Saints
the Saints are focused on the Saints in
this upcoming game Sunday we try not to
focus on all that's happening outside
this world unless it directly affects us
okay you're ready for the Bucs you got
the Saints taken on the Bucs I guessed
it you're your coach also lost a golf
bet with Doug Peterson so when the
Eagles come in they're gonna wear their
home uniforms or something like that you
heard something about I could care less
what color people are wearing I know if
they're the opposite color of my team
they're getting hit Cameron Jordan I
love talking to you man let's make this
a regular thing throughout the season
okay please you got my line I do have
your line and I have your Twitter
account at cam Jordan 94 thanks for
calling and really appreciate it
appreciate it rich you have a blessed
one do you got it right back at you
Cameron Jordan Saints defensive lineman
one of the best of the business here in
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience